-We are hanging out
with Ryan Reynolds!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Ryan is the owner
of Aviation gin,
so we're about to face off
in a special edition of Drinko.
Drinko, do you want to explain
how this works?
-Yes, I would love to.
Welcome to Drinko.
In this game,
you two will take turns
climbing my stairs
and dropping two of your disks
into the Drinko board.
The disks will plink down
and land in these plastic cups
containing some of my
favorite beverages,
such as maple syrup, clam juice,
and bacon, egg, and cheese.
You must then
combine those mixtures
with Aviation American Gin
to create a brand-new cocktail.
[ Laughter ]
-Thank you, very much.
-Wow.
-Thank you.
-You're welcome.
-Oh, my God.
-Thank you so much.
-No problem.
-I have such a weak stomach.
I'm not kidding.
-I know.
This kind of bummed me out.
All right. Here we go.
Ryan, why don't you go up first.
-Okay.
-Climb up there
and make yourself a cocktail.
-Eee! Ohh! Ohh! Unh!
Eee! Eee! Ohh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Drop the first disk
whenever you're ready, Ryan.
[ Drumroll ]
Ooh, ooh, ooh, aah, aah,
eee, eee, ooh, ooh!
-Not blood, not blood,
not blood.
-Twinkies!
-Oh, you lucked out.
That's good.
-What is that?
-Twinkies.
-Oh.
You lucked out.
I want Twinkies.
-I'd inject a Twinkie.
-Oh, my gosh.
-Drop your second disk.
-"I would inject a Twinkie."
-Round and round she goes.
Where she stops, Drinko knows.
-Not blood, not blood,
not blood, not -- Oh!
-What?!
-Grape soda!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-What do we got?
-This is the best.
Twinkies and grape soda.
-Oh, I can totally do that.
Please.
-This is easy.
I'm so mad, though.
-That's like 90%
of my child's diet.
That's great, please.
[ Laughter ]
-All right.
That's grape soda.
-Hoo!
Twinkies and grape soda.
[ Audience groans ]
Oh.
Actually, that just got
a little disgusting.
[ Laughter ]
Just throw a little in there.
In there.
-Yeah, yeah.
Okay, yeah.
-For a little flavor.
What do you want
to call this, Jimmy?
I made a new drink here.
-That is called the, uh...
-The Ruth Bader Gins-burg.
-Oh, hey! That's a good --
Yeah, I like that one.
All right.
Go for it, buddy.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Now it's your turn, James.
-Right?
-I would rather drink
spinal fluid than that.
[ Laughter ]
-All right, there you go.
-Oh.
-Eee! Ohh! Ohh! Eee! Oy! Eee!
-Oh, gosh, all right, all right.
I'm staying away from clam juice
and bacon, egg, and cheese.
-Go for blood.
Blood sounds good.
-Yeah, blood.
[ Laughter ]
I love that blood is there.
Oh, kombucha.
I don't -- Oh, my gosh.
-James, drop your disk.
-I'm freaking out right now.
-What's that, Drinko?
-Drop your disk.
-All right.
Calm down, dude.
-Put your disk back in.
-All right.
Come on, melted ice cream.
Melted ice cream.
Here we go.
-Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go,
go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Oh!
[ Laughs ]
-No!
-Twinkies!
-Oh!
Come on!
-What?
What is it?
-Give me a break.
-Twinkies.
-Twinkies?
-Yes.
-Yes! That where it ended up.
-Please.
-Whoo-hoo!
Come on, melted ice cream!
Here we go.
-Come on,
blood or bone broth.
-Oh, no!
Oh, no!
-Horseradish.
[ Laughter ]
-Yes!
Yes.
-Horseradish and Twinkies.
Mm-mmm, good.
-Oh, this is
gonna be amazing.
I'm so excited for you.
[ Laughter ]
-You're excited for me?
-Oh, yeah.
-Twinkies and horseradish?
-This is gonna be incredible.
Look at this.
[ Audience groans ]
-Yeah.
Just make sure
all of it's in -- Oh!
[ Audience groans, laughter ]
Wow.
It's like horseradish bile.
That is super gross.
Oh, yeah.
It's gonna be good.
Want a little of this?
-Yeah. Maybe a lot of that.
-There you go.
-All right, good, thank you.
-Yeah.
-[ Coughs ]
-[ Laughs ]
-Man up, Jim.
-Come on.
You got this.
-Twinkies and horseradish.
-You got this.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh!
-[ Vomits ]
-[ Laughs ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Groans ]
-Oh-ho-ho.
Oh, there's all kind -- wow.
-Just don't even look at it.
-Look at that.
You barfed up
your whole childhood.
Oh.
Revolting.
That's the first time you've
ever barfed on your own show?
All right.
-No.
[ Laughter ]
It isn't.
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, wait.
This is the final round.
We're gonna race to see
who gets to the top first.
-Really?
-No, but not now, but I mean --
All right.
Whoever --
-Has anyone thought to ask,
like, whose blood it is?
-Here --
No, I think it's a unicorn.
-Unicorn. Unicorn.
-Like a --
-Care Bear. Care Bear.
-Are you ready?
-All right.
-3, 2, 1, drop.
-Bacon, egg, and cheese!
Bacon, egg, and cheese!
-Grape soda and kombucha!
Ryan, drink.
-What is it?
-Wait. I threw mine.
I gotta do another one?
-No, no, we don't.
I just did it for fun.
What was it?
Who has to drink it, me?
Oh, Ryan does!
This is great.
-No!
-Yes!
Dude, do you like kombucha?
-It's like,
"What did I just order?"
-It's, like,
fermented pickle juice.
It's great.
-This one's called
the Van Wilder.
-Dude, you already did
grape soda.
-You know what?
-Thank you, Drinko.
Throw a blood in there.
-Oh.
Oh, snap.
-See, this is a --
This guy knows how to party.
Come on.
-Let's go with --
Let's go with the bone broth.
What -- What's the worst?
Clam juice?
-Clam juice.
-Bacon, egg, and cheese?
[ Audience shouting ]
-Where is -- oh!
Oh!
-Put some maple syrup in, too.
-Ryan, are you sure
you wanna do this, man?
-Let's go all-in.
-All right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Chuckles ]
♪♪
[ Audience gasps ]
-Oh!
Oh.
-This is grape juice.
-Oh. Yeah.
Get more of that.
-Oof.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Ugh.
-Oh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
No, we're good.
We're good.
-That's what I'm talking about!
Ryan Reynolds!
You are a legend!
♪♪
Ryan Reynolds, everybody.